it's game one of a four game series
between the padres and the colorado
rockies
joe moscow
making his 20th start of the year for
the padres
and ready to work to the rocks you
mentioned it just 11 wins away from
coarse field it's been a real
rough season for the rockies especially
on the road
two down for ryan mcmahon
swinging a miss and muskrobe strikes out
mcmahon in the inning kyle freeland now
goes to work against these padres
beginning with the
left fielder tommy pham
you have to throw strikes to tommy fan
fly ball to deep left field tapia going
back still going it's going to be over
his head and one hop up and out of the
stadium as that is a double
starts the bottom of the first inning
tommy pham
double to start things here in the first
inning and brings up fernando tatis jr
driven to left tapia won't get there
it's by him quickly to the wall here
comes fam
fernando is going to try for second
he'll be
padres take a one-nothing lead
he hesitated for second round first
and then said ah i'm going anyway and
gets in there and the only question was
was going to be able to stay on the bag
and he did
you know he hit this ball so hard once
again no chance for tapia a pitch up and
out of the zone at a fastball and he's
got the nice level swing now the race is
on fam had to hold his ground a little
bit
he scores easily now the race is on
a little down shift
get the rpms up tip toe stay on the bag
and it's a double-double
inning for san diego
where he turned it back on
one nothing padres top of the third
inning
swinging a miss made quick work of him
as he strikes out
it's a second strikeout for joe muskrobe
one out base is empty top of the third
nothing and two the pitch to top he has
swung on and missed he slams his bat
down might have even broken it just a
filthy breaking ball and back-to-back
strikeouts for musgrove to start the
third inning all of a sudden the feel
for that slider
has started to come back gets it in
underneath the hands of tapia
two outs via the k
now a grounder back up the middle
chronoworth ranging from the other side
of second the throw is good nice play by
jake cudaworth saraki's in the fourth
will have blackman's story and mcmahon
this is shallow left tommy pham i don't
think he can get there that's a trap no
it gets behind him in fact that
charlie's at second
with a bloop double he okay he might
have hurt his wrist on that dive
[Applause]
just a little
bleeder out the left field on the subaru
super mode and then watching fam come
after this
he lays out but then gets that man risk
caught underneath him
right there gets caught underneath
momentarily and that allows charlie to
get to second base
strike three call
bosco picks up his fourth k picked a
pretty good time to get it second time
mcmahon is down by way of the k
really good pitch by joe musgrove you
know after throwing breaking balls in
and in
i think he wanted that one in but it
froze mcmahon
right on the outside corner
and a nice frame job by austin nola
two down blackman at third base tying
run 90 feet away for sam hilliard
swinging a man said moscow will leave
blackman at third base
must grow of one of two strikeout
victims for freeland
and there's a good curveball and kyle
02 on fan
and that is strike three
kyle's feeling it now yeah i love when
he's marching around
throw it around fellas
let's go
he got in on him
tapia near the line will have a play
and it's a one two three fifth inning
for kyle freeland joe musgrove been a
little bit better five shutout innings
eight strikeouts for joe he's only
walked one and allowed three hits
senior numbers no two pitches swung on
and missed brennan rogers strikes out
making nine case for joe musgrove
really good lane changer
swinging a miss and make it ten
strikeouts for joe musgrove
got it going on he certainly does and
keep going there why not if they're
gonna keep offering just flip it up
there
[Applause]
10 strikeouts got a good ring to it
doesn't it sure does
deep third long throw for machado
not a problem
manny machado could sling it from
anywhere on the field
machado on third one out for will myers
and it gets off the glove of nunes
throws it to freeland the home plate
umpire called him safe he is going to be
out without even needing the review
machado
out at the plate 2-1 pitch is bounced up
the middle story behind second spins
throws high
hosmer's save myers trying to score out
at the plate and rio ruiz with a strike
to the plate fam walked he's still at
first with two down and it brings up
jake cronin work
connor worth to deep right field towards
the pole that paul's gone
into the ground zone off the ball
two-run home run padres take a
three-nothing lead
you know there are a lot of exciting
things in this game of baseball but one
of my favorites is a deep drive down the
lines
and you wait for it
and it kisses the football yes that's
awesome
two down in the ninth is the standard
one of petco park the fryer faithful do
popped up in a shallow center comes
grisham to run it down
trent grisham got a great break and the
gold globe center fielder runs in to
make the catch and ends this game
padres hold on to this one and win it
three to nothing tonight